[Musique effrayante]
You're gonna be scared...
Vous êtes décidément accro à toutes ces vidéos
d'histoires d'horreur, de trucs paranormaux, etc.
Vous aimez ne pas dormir, vous aimez vous faire du mal.
Vous aimez vraiment souffrir.
Écoutez, après m'être fait harceler par énormément de gens parmi vous, j'ai décidé de refaire une vidéo horreur !
Je me suis même pas fait harceler, c'était une prise d'otages.
Vous m'avez pris en otage. Vous m'avez menacé !
Eh, on se calme, il n'y a pas tout le temps des trucs flippant à raconter ?
Alors je prends mon temps.
Les deux ou trois dernières vidéos de ce genre on était sur le subreddit "Let's not meet"
Où des gens témoignent de trucs flippant qui leur sont arrivés, de vraies histoires.
On retourne sur un format un peu plus vieux, le format thread Twitter.
On avait d'ailleurs commencé ce format avec des threads Twitter
Je vous le rappelle... eh ben écouter aujourd'hui on revient aux sources
avec un nouveau thread qui est
FRANÇAIS !
Et oui oui oui !..
Et qui est, je trouve, excellent.
C'est parti pour le thread de @EL_CATERA — qu'on va appeler Michael tout au long de l'histoire pour des raisons de clarté.
Et à la fin on ira tous sur des forums obscures pour en savoir plus
parce que ça va nous faire bien bader !
Michael explique qu'il a remonté récemment de sa cave une malle
pour s'en servir comme élément de déco.
Comme il dit : "tout va bien me direz vous".
Et je suis déjà pas d'accord avec lui (rires).
Ne montez pas une malle qui est dans votre cave depuis un siècle
pour faire la déco de votre chambre !
C'est pas un bon plan, vraiment, il explique que récemment elle s'est mise à faire du bruit.
La putain de malle qui n'est pas une bonne
décoration plus vraiment, il dit être formel il y'a du bruit qui vient de l'intérieur de la malle aussi chelou que cela puisse paraître ce serait
trop simple qu'il puisse l'ouvrir tout de suite Michael précise qu'elle est verrouillée par un cadenas don à sa connaissance personne n'a
la clé, nickel du bruit qui vient d'une malle qui était dans sa cave depuis un siècle
et personne n'a de clé
génial
il va ensuite décrire un peu la malle en expliquant qu'elle fait environ un mètre vingt de long, qu'elle est très ancien et quelle date
probablement d'avant guerre on est donc sur un vieil objet vraiment, quelques minutes plus tard Michael est surpris par un nouveau bruit qui vient
de l'intérieur de la malle il décrit un peu le bruit et c'est apparemment une sorte de mélange entre un coup un
craquement et un bruit d'ongles qui gratte, aucun de ces trois bruits est rassurant aucun
bref la nuit passe Michael réussi à dormir en précisant qu'il a réussi à s'endormir à partir du moment où les bruits on
stopé voilà l'intro et maintenant on va suivre
l'histoire sur plusieurs jours parce que michael a fait des tweets quasiment tous les jours à propos de cette histoire là qui a vite dégénéré
le lendemain Michael dit avoir passé une très bonne nuit et revient sur ce qu'il a dit la veille en expliquant que c'est pas
un cadenas qui ferme la malle mais que c'est une serrure
directement incorporées dans la malle hé Michael on s'en bat les couilles que tu te sois trompé l'erreur est humaine parle nous de la malle
c'est quoi cette malle bordel on a le droit à une photo et la malle ressemble à ça
rien d'étonnant c'est vraiment une malle classique qui a deux petits trous de serrure une qui est verrouillée et l'autre qui semble avoir été forcée d'après
les dires de michael et il soulève un point intéressant pourquoi il y'a qu' une serrure qui a été forcée et pas l'autre pourquoi la
personne s'est arrêté en si bon chemin les gens vont répondre à michael en lui disant écoute
enregistre le bruit que tu entends qui vient de la malle pour qu'on puisse essayer de trouver ensemble, pour qu'on puisse aider à trouver une
explication rationnelle
par rapport à ce bruit à trouver ce que c'est et que tu arrête de te chier dessus,  notre ami a donc une bonne idée c'est de mettre
son téléphone en mode dictaphone
et de le poser à côté de la malle toute la nuit pour le lendemain des rush un truc de je sais pas combien d'heures et
essayer d'y trouver le fameux bruit qu'il a entendu à multiples reprises et qui vient de l'intérieur de la malle Michael se réveille tranquillement
à 11h30 le bâtard il nous fait attendre
il explique qu'il avait une soirée la veille etc
mais ça a marché il a trois heures d'enregistrement
je sais vous êtes déçu moi aussi, l'enregistrement s'est arrêté au bout de trois heures mais il a quand même réussi à chopper 2 3
moment où il y'a eu des craquements et des coups qu'on peut entendre en mettant le son très fort, écoutons ça
*bruit*
ah !..
c'est le craquement moi qui me dérange là ça se trouve dans la malle il ya juste un doigt comme ça coupé qui fait
ça
c'est
horrible bon
michael on t'aime on passe un bon moment tous ensemble mais maintenant tu prends ce qu'on appelle un marteau un pied de biche et tu
frappes sur ta malle pour l'ouvrir s'il te plaît
Merci, il fallait le faire 24 heures plus tôt mais c'est pas grave c'est bien ouverture de la malle est ce qu'il y'a dedans
c'est des papiers
vous êtes déçu moi aussi, quelques heures plus tard michael revient avec pas mal d'infos c'est les heures qu'il lui fallait pour décortiquer tout le
contenu de la malle, dans la malle il y avait apparemment des vieux papiers des notes des cartes des dessins
apparemment pas mal effacé à cause du temps qui est passé et aussi
trois objets, michael ouvre le premier, prend des photos et les partager avec nous et on peut voir que c'est un livre avec un trou
dans la couverture une vitre et de l'autre côté de la vitre se trouve une sorte d'objets
rougeâtre qu'on peut vaguement apercevoir mais ce pas très net dans le deuxième il trouve une vieille montre et un
bol avec une bougie au milieu et dans le troisième le truc le plus chelou une boîte recouverte
de plomb alors bien évidemment tout le monde lui demande d'ouvrir
cette fameuse boîte pour qu'on voie ce qu'il y'a dedans et c'est ce que michael va faire et ce qu'il y'a dedans c'est incompréhensible
il ya un
petit flacon poser dans du sel dans lequel se trouve un petit objet suspendu à l'aide de ce qui a l'air d'être un cheveu et
le tout est scellée par une sorte de feuille de métal qui fait le tour
bref c'est l'objet le plus énigmatique de tout ce qu'on a pour le moment et sous le sel qui avait dans la boîte se trouve
une photo de poissons
mecs ça fait combien d'interrogation d'un coup là 8
elle vient d'où cette malle qui avait dans ta cave c'est quoi l'histoire de cette mal qu'est ce qu'elle fout la demande à tes parents
à quelqu'un et c'est ce qui va faire michael il va appeler son père et ce dernier va lui raconter que la malle
appartenait à son arrière grand père ce qui est plutôt crédible puisque c'est vrai que souvent dans les caves ou dans son grenier on a
des objets qui peuvent dater parfois de une ou deux générations il ya des trucs comme ça de famille qui se transmettent de génération en
génération même moi y'en a dans la famille sauf que c'est pas des objets maudit comme celui-là a l'air de l'être et
et apparemment l'arrière grand père de michael était dans l'armée il a donc beaucoup voyagé ce qui selon lui
expliquerai la présence de cartes
de notes de tout un tas de trucs dans cette malle
on a donc trois éléments et on sait pas ce que c'est et là du coup les tweetos vont se lancer dans une grosse
recherche pour apporter des infos à michael pour essayer de comprendre qu'est ce que c'est que tous ces trucs tout d'abord il y'a quelqu'un qui
a reconnu la page du bouquin qu'on voit et ce serait celle d'un vieux bouquins de
1886 qui s'appelle le monde avant la création de l'homme écrit par camille flammarion et se serait apparemment un gros gros bouquin qui compile 900 gravure
mais à côté de ça plein de gens vont dire à michael que une boîte de plombs c'est pas
anodin et c'est souvent utilisé en sorcellerie pour confiner une entité
yes le mec a une relique des frères warren chez lui et il a ouvert le conte il explique que lui ça correspond pas à
ses croyances personnelles
il croit pas trop à tout ce délire de sorcellerie et tout ça mais il admet quand même que la présence de sel le
met sur la piste d'une sorte de sortilèges
on n'en sait donc plus sur deux colis celui dans lequel il y avait le livre, celui dans lequel il y avait la boîte en
plomb mais celui dans lequel il y avait la montre et le bol avec une bougie dedans on commet toujours pas à partir de là
on a plus news de michael jusqu'en début de soirée où il explique qu'il lui est arrivé un truc très badant
il explique être parti faire ses courses et que sur le chemin du retour
quelqu'un l'a suivi, Ok, est ce que t'es parano parce que tu as ouvert un truc maudit
peut-être est-ce que c'est l'esprit que tu viens de libérer en ouvrant cette putain de malle tu es en train de te hanter
peut-être je suis heureux de ne pas avoir de mal dans ma cave là qu'est ce qu'on est bien
arrivé devant son immeuble Michael s'est retourné pour regarder le gars qu'il soupçonne de l'avoir suivi et le mec a apparemment immédiatement détourné le
regard et il a fait genre d'être sur son téléphone
voilà comme n'importe quel mec qui panique quand il se fait prendre en flag
du coup notre ami va mettre un petit warning sur twitter en mode bon on a tous des théories on essaie tous de trouver des explications
rationnelles à ce qui se passe mais par contre je veux pas que ça atteigne ma vie privée donc faite pas des blagues de
genre c'est pas drôle si quelqu'un a trouvé mon adresse ben c'est juste pas marrant bref il met un gros stop au potentiel gens qui seraient
allés trop loin dans le délire mais ça c'était avant de recevoir un message sur twitter un peu creepy et oui le lendemain Michael
reçoit un message privé sur twitter d'un compte qui s'appelle est etiam nuper ad tergum ce qui ressemble clairement à du latin
et  le latin c'est comme c'est comme la bougie et
l'horloge bloqués ça fait partie des éléments ou c'est non on ne veut pas ça, se compte lui envoyer une vidéo et le message 3
3 3 à
3h33 dans la nuit alors la vidéo est dégueulasse mais on comprend ce qui se passe quelqu'un a filmé michael à travers sa fenêtre
michael envoie une frontale à ce mec en lui disant alors je sais pas si tu m'entends sale merde mais si tu recommences
j'appelle les flics
Michael soupçonne l'hypothèse d'un pote qui lui fait une blague
vu que le thread a pris un peu d'ampleur et qu'il a fait 1700 retweets c'est
possible on a tous des potes un peu qui vont loin dans la blague un des gros déconneur
sauf que il trouve que la blague est pas drôle et la phrase en latin veut dire il est trop tard pour reculer
moi je suis michael je remets tout dans la malle comme ça je la mets dans du feu et je change de pays
parallèlement quelqu'un va lui expliquer que
3h33 on appelle ça l'heure du prince et ça fait référence à satan alors cette personne précise qu'elle n'a aucune idée de si ça a un
rapport si c'est fait exprès ou pas mais voilà elle lâche l'info comme ça elle mais michael en pls et puis elle s'en va comme ça
apparemment à cette heure-là de la nuit l'écart entre le monde des vivants et celui des esprits devient beaucoup plus ténu ce qui peut permettre
d'entrouvir la porte à certains
malveillants comme les démons ou les fantômes c'est l'opposé de trois heures de l'après-midi lors des miracles qui est
traditionnellement considéré comme lors de la mort du christ sur sa croix
OK , autre personne qui déclare être sataniste va demander à
michael si le bol et la bougie dégage une odeur qui lui semblerait familiale et effectivement d'après notre ami le bol dégage une odeur de
soufre ce qui veut dire selon notre utilisateur
satanistes il ya peut-être une invocation étant donné que le souffre est liée dans cette culture là à une invocation moi je connais rien à
tout ce délire ça me fait bader et je veux pas connaître je n'ai pas envie de connaître que ce soit vrai ou
faux je n'ai pas envie de savoir ça me fait peur dans les deux cas c'est horrible et il va pas s'arrêter là le gars
et va lui expliquer que en gros quand un sorcier conclu un pacte avec le diable il reçoit une puissance extraordinaire et en échange de
ce pouvoir il doit renier le baptême est livré son âme aux démons pour l'éternité vous savez les fameux pacte avec le diable qu'il ya eu
dans je ne sais pas combien de film et une fois ce marché conclu satan serait liée à son tour et serait forcé d’obéir  pour
un temps déterminé et pendant ce temps il se laisserait par exemple enfermés dans des objets comme des malles
ah oui bref vous l'avez compris tout le monde parle de sorcellerie à michael il y'a tous les
indices d'un délire de sorciers le sel
l'odeur de souffre la bougie la montre arrêté tout mais malgré tout la nuit passe elles se passent plutôt bien puisqu'il ya aucun bruit qui
vient de la malle les choses semblent s'être calmées
jusqu'au lendemain peu après minuit où michael entend quelqu'un toqués à
multiples reprises à sa fenêtre il décide de sortir et de filmer pour avoir une preuve a montré à la police parce que souvenez vous
il avait dit qu'il appellerait la police si quelque chose se repasse dans la vraie vie et c'est le cas cette fois ci et je
vous laisse regarder cette vidéo
Un mec capuché et qui semblait fuir et qui en voyant michael le poursuivre a décidé de ne plus fuir de faire l' inverse de
défuir et de rusher vers michaël, rassurez vous il va bien il a réussi à rentrer chez lui avant de se faire choper et il
a fermé à double tour sa porte d'entrée et cette fois c'est bon il décide d'aller voir les flics le lendemain pourquoi le lendemain parce
qu'il veut pas y aller à des heures où il y'a personne dehors il veut y aller quand il y'a du monde ça le rassure
il est un peu en pls il devient un peu parano
mauvaise nouvelle Michael est allé voir les flics et ils lui on  juste dit ok on peut rien faire pour toi
effectivement avoir une vidéo d'un mec qui court vers toi et qui est capuché et ben les flics ils
peuvent rien faire ils vont dire ah merde bah ça se reproduit et que t'as plus d'infos bien nous voir mais là
ça suffit pas et l'après midi il prend la meilleure décision il va voir un prêtre ah
il
était temps sauf qu'une heure plus tard il est deg et il traite le prêtre d'incompétents parce qu'il y aurait juste dit viens prié ce soir
dieu te protégera moi je suis agnostique donc je ne connais rien du tout à la religion mais en même temps tu voulais qu'il fasse
quoi se prêtre tu veux qu'il vienne te changer la serrure qu'est ce que te veux qu'il fasse à part te dire ça en vrai, bref la
nuit passe une nouvelle journée commence
et là c'est un déferlement de mauvaises nouvelles et on approche en plus la fin du thread au moment où je fais la vidéo michael
explique qu'il n'arrive plus à dormir il pense que tout ça a un impact de ouf sur sa santé mentale
il va même expliqué qui s'est surpris à se parler tout seul ce qu'il ne fait apparemment
jamais et il aurait cherché pendant plusieurs heures la provenance d'une odeur de poisson pourri dans son appart
le latin je suis chiant mais vraiment le latin la montre la bougie l'odeur du poisson pourri
run away, bref il prend une décision importante cette fois il va passer quelques jours chez une amie à lui et il a une bonne
idée qui est en réalité une très mauvaise idée c'est d'emmener les colis ainsi que les cartes qu'il a trouvé dans la malle
Tu t'es hanté tout seul et en plus tu vas hanter tes amis bien joué, il explique que si ce à quoi il pense est correct
alors il aura besoin des cartes et du reste mais à quoi il pense et bien écoutez je sais pas
et en plus on va pas avoir de nouvelles pendant
48 heures à partir de là mais il va quand même finir par nous en donner et nous expliquer tout d'abord qui va mieux qu'il
a profité de sa quiétude pour se
reposer qu'il a pu faire le point sur la situation il va aussi en profiter pour remercier tous les gens qui lui ont apporté des
informations qu'on essayait de l'aider de le tirer de là et que toutes les discussions qu'il a pu avoir avec les gens qui suivait l'histoire
l'ont beaucoup aidé quand il dit tout ça on sent qu'il a compris le problème qui sait ce qui se passe mais tu peux pas
trop en dire sous peine de se mettre en danger il va quand même admettre qu'il a fait une erreur
c'est d'ouvrir cette putain de mal et que selon lui
le truc le plus logique à faire ce n'est pas de refermé bêtement la malle et de la remettre dans la cave
il pense que le vrai problème est ailleurs c'est quelque chose de beaucoup plus vieux que c'est quelque chose qui vient de son arrière grand
père que lui 100 ans après il pourra jamais savoir pourquoi et comment c'est arrivé
mais par contre grâce aux cartes qu'il a emmenait il pense savoir où c'est arrivé là on n'a pas eu de news depuis
six jours
au moment ou je fait $cette vidéo et les derniers mots de michael s'était il faut que je répare les erreurs de mon ancêtre que je remette
les colis à leur place je peux pas vous en dire plus pour le moment puisque j'ai peur quand vous donnant des infos j'en
donne aussi à ceux qui me veulent du mal et je sais pas qui ils sont mais j'ai pas du tout envie de tout risquer
pour un simple tweet ne vous inquiétez pas je vous tiendrai au courant de toute avancée dans mes recherches
c'était y'a six jours
Michael est ce que ça va
est-ce que c'est toi maman qui te trouve dans cette malle et qui va gratter la parois de la malle comme ça pour faire peur
à son prochain propriétaire
putain
eh bien écoutez les amis je crois que nous arrivons à la fin de ce thread au moment ou je tourne cette vidéo et je
trouve ça très cool qu'on n'est pas encore la fin ça faisait longtemps qu'on n'avait pas fait un thread ou des histoires autour du diable
de la religion des sectes des reliques de la sorcellerie
j'avais envie de faire ce thread aussi parce que j'ai reçus après avoir fait pas mal de vidéos sur les trucs d'horreur etc..beaucoup de
mails de gens qui
témoignaient des trucs bizarres et c'était toujours autour de la religion des trucs qui sont passés dans leurs enfance genre des
crois qui se sont retournés
des,  bref j'ai reçu plein de trucs de ce genre là et d'ailleurs les rares films d'horreur devant lesquelles je suis
vraiment mal c'est ceux qui traitent de ça ça me fait bader  et ça me dépasse ça me met mal je connais rien de tout
ça en plus donc j'ai pas de de truc rationnelle pour me rassurer juste je me chie dessus et je fais
j'ai adoré ce thread j'ai hâte de voir la suite je sais pas quand ce sera mais il y aura probablement je vous mettrais le lien
du thread  du coup dans la description pour vous puissiez checker la suite en direct
en tout cas passer une bonne nuit
si vous avez une malle et ben écoutez, mettez la dans la cave et la remontée jamais, hein pour cette nuit comme ça vous
dormez bien et on se dit a bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo au revoir à très vite